prices down during the cost of living
crisis
[Music]
good morning this is inking live in our
business and economic news from the
Heart of the City
the Activision Blizzard the American
computer games publisher has reacted
with Fury after the competition of
markets Authority blocked its near 70
billion dollar takeover by Microsoft the
company whose game titles include Call
of Duty OverWatch and World of Warcraft
said the decision showed the UK was
closed for business while Microsoft said
it reflected a flawed understanding of
the way the market and the way the
relevant Cloud technology actually works
well joining me now is Sarah Cardell
she's chief executive of the competition
and markets Authority Sarah welcome to
you Microsoft I thought coming
dangerously close there to saying you
don't know what you're doing
well we certainly do know what we're
doing and we have done a very thorough
investigation our investigation has
taken over six months we've looked very
carefully at all of the evidence and we
have concluded that the right thing is
to keep this Market open for competition
and make sure that a whole range of
businesses can can compete effectively
in this market as it grows and develops
one thing that raised eyebrows was the
fact that you were lighted on the clouds
Market in particular I mean this is
quite a nascent Market a lot of people
are not necessarily playing games
through the cloud at the moment is this
something that you you've a decision
you've taken with an eye in the future
perhaps
yeah so you're absolutely right we
focused in on our concerns in cloud
gaming and it is an Emerging Market but
it's one that's growing rapidly the
number of users has tripled over the
last couple of years and we see this as
an area where it's really important to
keep competition open to make sure that
a whole range of competitors can get in
and can develop their product to offer
the greatest range of innovation and
choice for businesses so what we saw was
that Microsoft already has a very strong
position in cloud gaming they combine
their position across Windows across
Xbox and across their Cloud
infrastructure and the merger would have
brought that strong position together
with the really strong portfolio of
games as you mentioned that Activision
have and that would have had an impact
on the ability of other Cloud providers
to compete effectively in this market
going forward so we wanted to make sure
that this Market was able to deliver
real Innovation and real Choice going
into the future a lot of people were
surprised that you didn't have an issue
though with the consoles Market even
though there's evidence to suggest that
micro soft has been talking about making
some games exclusive only to the Xbox
and shutting out the PlayStation
so we looked carefully at that aspect of
the deal as well and as you may know in
our original provisional findings we did
identify potential concerns in that
market but we considered the additional
evidence that came into us and we
concluded that those concerns were not
necessary and we focused instead on the
concerns that we found in cloud gaming
no Microsoft and Activision Blizzard are
unhappy with the remedies that uh they
proposed you you didn't go along with
and vice versa is there any room for
horse trading there potentially
so we've done a very thorough
investigation and as part of that
investigation we gave very careful
consideration to the remedies that they
put forward but we concluded on the
basis of all the evidence that we saw
before us that those remedies were not
sufficient to ensure effective
competition in the market going forward
what we have done through our decision
is make sure that that market remains
open to effective competition I mean
they thought some of the remedies that
you would regard acceptable such as
hiven off Call of Duty were unacceptable
I think it's what's important here is to
make sure that the market remains open
so the remedies would have introduced a
regulatory oversight of this Market that
is not really the way you want to see a
new Dynamic Market emerging you want to
make sure that market is truly open to
competition and we think the better
option is therefore to to prohibit the
deal and let the market develop fully
and freely in the way that it should
are you concerned about these comments
from Activision that uh this decision
essentially suggests the UK is not open
for business
but Microsoft and
I clearly have their own commercial
incentives forget for getting this deal
through but I fundamentally don't agree
with those comments actually what this
decision shows is that the UK is very
much open for business and it's very
much open to investment because we want
open markets that will Thrive that will
attract a strong investment that will
deliver lower prices greater choice to
Consumers and also allow a full range of
businesses including UK startups to
flourish and grow in these markets
Activision's chief executive Bobby kotik
says you've been co-opted by the ftc's
ideology what do you say to that
I say is that the UK and the CMA is here
to protect UK businesses and UK
consumers we take on decisions based on
the evidence that we have seen we have
identified a competition problem in this
deal and we have taken action
accordingly all right Sarah we have to
leave it there really appreciate you
joining me today thank you thank you
very much
now the new director general of the CBI
says she's confident the business group
will win back the trust of members our
ministers within six months but admits
it will have to completely change in
order to survive allegations of sexual
misconduct and a toxic culture or ran
Newton Smith began work at the CBI this
week with its future in doubt following
allegations that two employees were
raped by colleagues she's been speaking
to our business correspondent Paul Kelso
I'm determined we'll definitely be at
that table in six months time we need to
be right because that's what our members
want from us and we remember membership
organization are you really confident
CBI can survive
to be leading those conversations I am
really confident that CBI can survive
it's not going to be the same CBI that
that we've seen over the past few weeks
for sure and it's not going to be the
same organization uh that's been there
we have to completely change and we will
we were aware of any of this toxicity in
the world do you have any concerns that
this kind of thing might be going on
when you were working here
look when I was here I you know if if
people raised issues with me with me I
supported them and and I think and look
this is really challenging right and
when things happen to an organization
and the stories we have heard are so
harrowing right and and everyone feels
them really deeply they're shocking
they're painful what practically do you
do to start changing the culture
I think it starts with listening right
and and I think it starts with humility
and
I think that's you know what's really
hard coming into this job uh as a leader
is I have to come into this job and I've
got a staff you know and people who are
broken who've gone through a really
really terrible time and I think what is
difficult in this organization in
particular right is when things happen
it's it's in the news every day people
wake up and read about themselves their
organization their staff every day in
the newspapers and then they have to
come in and deliver their job and it's
really really tough and it's really
personal right
now the government is set today to
publish its long-awaited gambling white
paper setting out tougher regulations
and it says a fit for the digital age
campaigners are calling for Le'Veon
gambling companies affordability checks
and maximum Stakes for online slot
machines the culture secretary Lucy
Fraser says the changes will redress the
power imbalance between punters and
operators who are joining me now to talk
about this is Neil Banbury he's UK
general manager of the gambling operator
Kindred Group which includes Brands such
as 32 red and unibet Neil welcome to you
do you accept that there's a need for
tougher regulation
yeah good morning thank you for having
me uh yeah so look we really welcome the
white paper today we support the
Ambitions to bring the regulatory
environment into the digital age uh and
obviously we wait to see the full
details of it later today but you know
we obviously are expecting a
comprehensive set of of reforms and we
look forward to continuing to contribute
into the debate to help this impact uh
customers in the best way but also to
ensure the UK is uh the safe as safe as
it possibly can be for those customers
there's a Punchy uh piece by Lucy Fraser
in the times today she says gambling
companies are exploiting addicts and
print disproportionately hitting poorer
communities what's your response to that
yeah look our business model is rooted
in sustainable play you know we're a
listed business and we are heavily
incentivized that our financial results
are sustainable and so you know our
investors expect us to deliver
sustainable Financial results and they
expect us to have a meaningful
sustainability agenda so we're working
very hard on that as a business we've
been public now for a couple of years
with our journey towards zero which is
our ambition to achieve zero percent of
the revenue from high-risk behaviors
we've made strong progress on that we're
down to three percent uh but that
clearly indicates there's still uh
progress for us to make but it's a
journey that we're very committed to we
share our progress and we welcome
collaboration and contribution uh from
anyone that can help us on that Journey
can you live with a maximum stake on
online slot machines
yes I also think it's really important
here that we acknowledge that we're not
starting from a standing start on on uh
some of these issues so we have been
trialling maximum Stakes on our slots
over recent uh months and quarters we've
been trialling uh even more
sophistication than that where we can
have different uh slot limits depending
on the profile of the product and the
profile of the customer uh and so we're
actually starting to build up a lot of
data now that's going to be hugely
valuable I think for us to contribute
into consultations around the uh around
things like slot limits for moving
forward it is the case though isn't it
with some of these online games the
rapidity of these games mean that you
can lose a lot of money very very
quickly far more rapidly than you can in
a physical environment
uh I think that used to be uh a lot more
true than it is uh today today there are
also uh significant controls in place
around
um some spending limits and thresholds
where further checks uh needs to take
place uh so again there's going to be
content hopefully in the white paper
that allows that conversation to evolve
you know we know so far there are things
that have proven very effective that
we're doing uh in terms of being able to
create an environment where arm
minimization is is a core part
um but we also know that there are
certain things that we're doing that is
not uh having the effect of keeping
sustainable play within a licensed
environment so again that data that
we're collecting is going to be
hopefully very valuable evidence as the
government now moves the consult on some
of the specific issues they're looking
to address with this white paper
now we're told that there may be a one
percent compulsory levy on the gambling
company profits to help treat addicts I
mean bearing in mind what you've just
said about being a listed company in
shareholders having certain expectations
uh of you can can you survive that
yeah absolutely the the industry has
made uh commitments to funding uh anyway
and we've been moving in that direction
for us the most important thing uh with
any monies raised in in this way is that
it goes to funds or continues to fund uh
the Charities that are doing very
valuable uh work in this space already
and also that it funds uh you know truly
independent and evidence-led research
that's that's a good thing uh for the
industry so uh yeah we're not uh over
overly concerned with that a number of
MPS have expressed concerns that the
legislation may be watered down
following uh campaigning by groups such
as yourself how much have you spent on
lobbying
yeah look I mean we have uh looked to
engage with the government as as this
white paper process has evolved that
will continue to be true through the
consultation I think it's really
important here to acknowledge that uh is
there's a very fine balance to try and
strike uh with gambling regulation it's
the past time that's enjoyed by millions
and millions in the UK and the industry
will acknowledge that there are problems
and there is harm that can be caused
um but it's at very low rates and even
though but that you know the harm itself
can obviously be serious and severe
um but to get that balance right to
continue to ensure that sustainable play
takes place within the licensed
environment uh is really important so
we've we've obviously looked to engage
and to to make representations so far in
the process and we'll continue to do
that
Before I Let You Go you obviously
sponsor a number of football clubs
including Glasgow Rangers and
Middlesbrough how much of a hit to the
business is phasing out that sponsorship
gonna mean
yeah look the
um the Premier League have made a
decision to take a voluntary
um
uh change with with the way that
gambling companies can sponsor on the
front of shirts uh we're really proud of
our model of sponsorship we have two key
aims with when we sponsor clubs the
first is that we invest in the club and
its Community to drive benefit there so
our partners have been able to scale up
a lot of efforts around mental health in
their communities Etc and the second is
that we've used the most prominent
assets to promote say for gambling
Behavior you know we've gone from a
couple of years ago somewhere between 20
and 30 percent of our customers using
safer gambling tools to now well over 50
and there's no coincidence there that
we've been putting safer gambling
messages and the use of control tools on
the front of shirts Etc so you know we
think that there are ways that football
and gambling should continue to work
together and and that can be for the
benefit of the football clubs and it can
be for the benefit of their communities
but also for the benefit of achieving an
environment that's sustainable for
gambling as well okay now you've got to
leave it there appreciate you joining me
today thanks very much thank you
some other business news stories for you
now and a strong showing in China and
other Emerging Markets have helped
AstraZeneca to better than expected
results during the first three months of
the year the drugs giant reported sales
of 10.9 billion dollars for the quarter
that was unchanged on the same period a
year ago however stripping out the
impact of covid vaccines where demand
has fallen sales were ahead by 15 year
on year Pascal sorio astrazeneca's chief
executive said he was impressed by the
growth and pace of innovation he was
seeing in China which underscored the
competitive advantage of the company's
leading presence there well they said
continue to enjoy strong sales growth
among its Blockbuster Cancer Treatments
but Fox ego which is its medication for
type 2 diabetes heart failure and
chronic kidney disease also grew sales
by 37 during the quarter
the household and consumer goods joint
Unilever said this morning that it
expects to raise prices less
aggressively during the rest of the year
the company whose Brands include Purcell
Dove Magnum and Marmite said that
inflation would add around one and a
half billion euros to its costs in the
first half of this year before being
significantly lower in the second half
which would mean price increases would
taper off but the company stressed it
did not expect to see cost deflation
well Alan joke the outgoing chief
executive said Unilever had only passed
on around three quarters of the cost
increases it had been experiencing to
its customers sales during the first
three months of the year Rose by ten and
a half percent on an underlying basis to
14.8 billion euros which was better than
expected
a strong performance from its credit
card business and its UK retail banking
division helped Barclays raise pre-tax
profits periods during the first three
months of the year by 16 to a better
than expected 2.6 billion pounds well
that was despite the lender having to
set aside 524 million pounds to cover
loans it does not now expect to be fully
repaid chiefly among U.S credit card
customers well the bank's ring fenced UK
arm saw its profits in the quarter rise
by 30 thanks to an increase in the net
interest margin that's the difference
between what it charges borrowers and
pays deposits on the back of the bank of
England's interest rate Rises or
Barclays said its income from Consumer
loans had fallen as customers had
reduced their borrowing and taken a more
prudent approach
and Sainsbury's has reported a drop in
full year profits as the benefits of
covet driven grocery sales unwind and
the company failed to recoup all of the
cost inflation it has been incurring
pre-tax profits during the year to the
4th of March fell by 5 on an underlying
basis to 690 million pounds well Simon
Roberts the chief executive said this
also reflected the fact that Sainsbury's
had spent more than 560 million pounds
on price Cuts during the last two years
he said that as a result the UK's second
largest Supermarket was the best value
compared with its competitors than it
had been for many years
now last year was a tough one for
clanais the fintech company saw its
valuation cut from 46 billion dollars to
7 billion dollars in its latest funding
Rand the specialist in buying I pay
later Services also racked up a one
billion loss but undeterred the company
is today announcing the first of its
twice yearly product updates for joining
me now is Sebastian simeonkowski he is
the founder and chief executive of clana
Sebastian good to see you this morning
what jumps out at me here is that uh
you're looking Beyond bmpl services
yeah very much so and great to thank you
for having me back I
um you know but it's actually been part
of klona for a long period of time right
I mean over a third of our transactions
are already debit transactions pay now
transactions and we have for a long
period of time believed that financial
services are going to transform
dramatically over the coming decade
um basically becoming this you know AI
powered digital Financial assistant that
helps you save time save money and make
you less worried about your finances
when I heard you referring to that
Barclay profit I was just thinking again
I mean it's amazing the excess profits
that exist in this industry and it's
been because of the lack of cuts for
Mobility lack of proper competition due
to the high barriers of Entry we're now
using the AI tools and clone has 150
million consumers to start offering more
and more richer services in in product
search in product Discovery in the
retail banking Associated products and
it's very very exciting since there's so
much opportunity to bring better
services to consumers in this area you
mentioned uh using AI more to
personalize uh shopping Council for uh
consumers give me an idea in practice
what that might look like
well I think you know the division of
client for since 15 when we pivoted in
this direction was already back then IAI
right so we had this idea it's like
where are banking services eventually
going to end up and we we thought like
one day you wake up in the morning and
your computer will tell you digital
Financial system will tell you hey I've
analyzed your mortgage or I've analyzed
your spending or I've analyzed your
electricity bills or whatever it might
be and I realized that I could save you
X pounds let's say 10 pounds on your
mortgage a month by switching from Bank
a to Big B and best of all I'll do all
the paperwork for you the only thing you
need to do is to say yes and so when you
when you think about that you realize
that's going to happen like that's the
direction of financial services what it
also means this means the end of those
success profits that you were referring
to in Barclays those excess profits are
gone you know banks have been obsessed
as you said about maximizing interest
rate spreads so giving you as little as
possible on your deposit bank and
maximizing your cost of your borrowing
now that's not possible in the world
where you have a digital assistant that
helps you and can move and help you move
between different providers and that's
the world we're moving towards and
obviously for cloner than being active
in this industry we want to be that
digital Financial assistant and so when
we now started seeing things like chat
GDP open AI we were like wow things that
we thought would take maybe another five
to ten years to accomplish we actually
see can be accomplished in you know a
few years so it's super exciting I think
we're applying AI now in 14 different
Services
um internally we're doing tons of
different products and initiatives and
we're exploring the technology and I am
amazed and surprised and I think it has
very it's going to have very very real
implications on all businesses and much
faster than anything we've seen before I
expect to see very very major
implications already one or two years
from now and you've got to remember this
comes from somebody who was like always
very skeptical at new stuff like I've
been you know skeptical about crypto for
10 years and still is so I'm not the
person that usually would you know would
be alarmist about new stuff but this is
different
you mentioned there that you are
partnering with chat GPT but as you say
you also have your own in-house AI
capability how much are you spending
right now on on that
uh a lot and increasingly so right we've
also
um have fantastic talent that has
experience from this from all over the
world not the least China which is you
know if you take as an example when it
comes to product recommendations and
product search in in the Western World
we're still used to searching
um while we're not we're not blown away
by recommendations of products to
ourselves like if you look at but if you
look at China a few years ago you know
in when it comes to e-commerce 80
percent was search driven and 20 was
product uh recommendations nowadays you
open the Chinese e-commerce apps 80 90
is recommendations so it's products
finding you saying like this is an
awesome product for you and only 10 20
of the purchases actually comes from
search right so so that's you see how
far in advance that AI has become to
help you find the products that are
relevant for you and that's why it's
obviously very keen to us because a
massively growing part of our business
is matching uh consumers to new brands
to new products this is our fastest
growing Revenue line it's growing over
you know a few hundred percent it's
becoming a very you know significant
piece of our business and it's obviously
because customers have decided to
entrust a lot of data with us we
understand those consumers really well
and they're you know their preferences
their brands that they like the products
that they purchase and so forth so that
makes us very very
um well suited to serve these uh these
use cases
briefly Sebastian before I let you go
you committed late last year to trading
profitably this year for the first time
in in three years are you going to be
able to do that with all this money
you're spending on AI right now yeah and
you know the thing is also AI is making
us so much more efficient I think one
thing that I I feel maybe Tech leaders
in the world should be a little bit more
honest about I mean Goldman Sachs made
this estimate of 300 million jobs that
could potentially be at risk I don't
think that is unrealistic I think that
this is going to change it's hopefully
going to make for more fun work less you
know boring work and so forth but I do
think it will have a significant impact
on the composition of jobs and as a
consequence I think you know politicians
and leaders across the world should also
think about you know it's it's easy to
say there will always be new jobs
created but I was in Brussels the other
day There's 7 000 translators working in
Brussels deep ell is so good at
translation you don't really need those
seven thousand translators anymore and
if I'm a 55 year old translator in
Brussels you know I'm not going to
become a YouTuber influencer so I think
you know we have to also think from a
from a bigger picture here what are we
how we're going to support people who
are going to be affected by these I
think that's very critical but for clana
in particular for us yes we are reaching
profitability you know
um we are uh we have aspired and we
think we're going to be able to
accomplish that by summer uh we're very
close to that we have you know uh a year
ago we booked a negative EBT of about
150 million dollars on a single month
we're now down to about 30
um and we are seeing very very uh
positive development on all our gross
profit metrics uh it cross established
markets new markets like the US uh UK
and in the same time we've also
obviously had to take the tough decision
of making
um uh reductions in in a number of
employees and so forth about a year ago
so so we're trending really well and
we're expecting to see profit um
somewhere around summer
all right always good to talk to you
Sebastian thanks for joining me today
thank you for having me
a bit of breaking news to bring you the
union has left has just announced that
train drivers are to stage three fresh
strikes in its long-running dispute
overpay including on the day of the FA
Cup Final on the 3rd of June more not
throughout the morning here on Sky News
but in the meantime still to come here
on Ian King live we'll have a look at
how Global markets are doing this
Thursday morning stay with us
foreign
[Music]
Ty we've got malteser Twix let's do it
slowly maltesers Twix banty a bounty
chocolate Galaxy yeah galaxy uh a Milky
Way Milky Way of course and uh Snickers
I think at the end Snickers at the end
and what about on his lapels the the
epaulets epileps we have I kept making
that mistake sorry we got yeah bounties
and galaxies and milky ways and Twix and
you can see in the collar which was the
trickiest bit a whole line of Milky Ways
and the ends of the maltesers which I've
used up the the ends that we cut to make
the maltesers yeah the bits you cut off
you put around the collar at the top
that's right and you
styled it on looking at hours and hours
of footage of him yeah that's right yeah
and uh and then from there made lots of
sketches and Tim Simpson the sculptor
created the head and Clay first so we
had to get that just right because
obviously everybody knows what Charles
looks like we didn't want to get that
wrong and then created a mold and I cast
it in chocolate and then reused
um yeah nearly 17 liters of of melted
celebrating chocolates
uh well hopefully we're gonna share it
with everybody and uh and um so you're
going to take it along the Route on the
day or who you're sharing it with we're
not quite sure yet but I think I think
we've got lots of people to show it to
you first yeah and is it solid
this is solid okay solid you're not
saying our King's an airhead are you
well there is a little bit of it
exactly that amazing how much you think
it's worth no idea oh Priceless yeah to
me and I know it was an absolute schlep
but my goodness mate absolutely
[Music]
time for look at this morning's business
Pages little debate about what the big
story of the day is the financial times
leaves its print edition with Activision
blizzards Fury the competition of
markets Authority for blocking its
takeover by Microsoft the paper's Lex
column says the decision will have
little impact on Microsoft's profits and
says shareholders in the company should
not be concerned the ft is currently
leading its Digital Editions with its
own interview with the cbi's new
director General reince Newton Smith in
which she tells the Ft the employer's
organization is likely to have to change
its name well the times also leads its
business pages with Activision Blizzard
Microsoft it's business columnist
Alastair Osborne indicates he thinks the
CMA has made the right decision the
paper also reports on last night's
results from meta Platforms in which the
owner of Facebook and Instagram reported
its first quarterly sales growth in
nearly a year well that story also makes
a front page of the daily telegraph's
business section for the vapor leads
with the report on the embattled
Californian lender first Republic's
attempts to secure a rescue deal
following a fresh punch in its share
price that reignited concern Sons about
the health of the U.S banking system
what do you want to me today is Daryl
Barker he's editor of the Wall Street
Journal for Europe the Middle East and
Africa tour good to see you this morning
obviously the big story right now in the
U.S is uh the uh goings-on in uh in
Congress to try and reach a settlement
over the U.S debt ceiling yeah so this
is um it might sound a little Arcane to
viewers here in the UK it's basically in
the US there's a ceiling to the level
that that can rise to and that has to be
raised
um by Congress periodically as as debts
grow in the U.S and there have been
standoffs in the past
um and this one is looking quite spicy
potentially
um where the Biden Administration is
refusing to tie Cuts in spending to
um uh so the Republicans want cuts and
spending in order to raise the debt
ceiling and and the Biden Administration
is refusing to link those two things
together so at the moment there's a
standoff
um I think most people in these
situations think that um the US is not
going to risk uh its position
um as as one of the great credits in the
world by defaulting on its debt that
said in 2011 uh when I was living in the
United States there was a debt ceiling
standoff which did get very tense and s
p actually downgraded U.S debt because
it got so tense and markets reacted
pretty aggressively back then so there
is precedent for some Market turbulence
on the back of this yeah I remember it
well but uh I mean the interesting thing
is the markets do seem quite sanguine at
the moment that there will be some sort
of agreement reached
yeah because historically I mean there's
always been this this tension there's
always been
um this attempt to you know use it as a
way to to reign in spending by the
Republicans that's not an uncommon
situation and usually it gets resolved
because nobody really wants to default
on uh U.S debt obviously so
um I think that the challenge this time
is in the House of Representatives the
Republican majority is already very
narrow and Kevin McCarthy is the speaker
is trying to to keep that majority
together so you know there's a dynamic
here that is is more complex than usual
I mean the countries like China have for
years resented the fact that the dollar
is the reserve Global Currency that it's
it really is a form of U.S examiney I
mean the Americans would be mad to risk
throwing that away wouldn't they and uh
potentially opening up the the world to
other currencies
I think the yeah the logic of that is
not lost on everybody for sure but again
you know as we as we know here in the UK
political debates can end up
um going to places which aren't
necessarily economically sensible so uh
you know I think you know the chance of
this ends in a U.S default I think is
very very very small I think the risk
that there's a lot of nerves as we get
closer to the date where it really
begins to
um to get serious you know there is
definitely the chance that markets start
to get a bit more volatile and you're
already beginning to see in the bond
market
um you know people are buying short
dated bonds that mature
um before the summer when people think
that the limit will really be hit
um and not keen to buy the um the bonds
that mature in the summer so there's a
bit of a distortion uh going on there
already and the US is already taking
special measures
um to to not hit the debt ceiling so
like not investing in
um the time in Civil Service retirement
account and and stuff like that so
there's already special measures
happening and we're not entirely sure
when exactly you hit that point where
you hit the debt ceiling briefly told
what about Microsoft Activision Blizzard
I mean I think it's intriguing that some
commentators are saying well look
Microsoft doesn't really need this deal
anyway I mean it's numbers on Tuesday
night was so good
yeah look it's Microsoft is obviously
this enormous company now so this is
only a part of their business
um that said you know this is the
biggest deal that they've ever tried to
do and it's something that they
um you know they're putting a lot of
money time and energy into achieving as
they try to build out this streaming
service on their XBox platform so
um you know most things in the scheme of
Mark of Microsoft are going to be small
because of the scale of the company but
this is a pretty serious strategic thing
for them given given the scale of this
deal
got to leave it there good to catch up
with you this morning thank you thanks
very much
a bit of breaking news to bring you
during the last few minutes uh Pat
Cullen who's the general secretary of
the RCN the Royal College of Nursing
she's also the chief executive she's
been speaking at the high court ahead of
a legal hearing about the nurse's strike
action let's hear what she's had to say
now that you're here no absolutely do
not the courts will decide the outcome
for today
um but what I would say is that Steve
Barkley may get um a legal win today but
what he has done is he has lost the
public and he has certainly lost nursing
so he has a short-term gain but long
term there's no trust whatsoever from
any of our nursing staff who are in this
government and certainly the public if
you look at what the public are saying
we are the most trusted profession and
we're being dragged through the courts
by the least trusted group of people in
England now what does that say about
this country and about the people that's
leading it the people of this country
know better and they deserve better and
they certainly didn't think that the
clubs of this government would turn to
slaps and slaps in the court house very
quickly this is no way to treat our
nursing staff the people you see
standing here today and any other
country throughout the world would say
the way to do this is through
conciliation and negotiation not
dragging our nurses through the
corporate
foreign
suffered another major sell-off last
night hit its lowest level for a month
on the back of rising fears over a
possible U.S recession and news of a
rise in Russian crude exports it's
rallied a little bit this morning Battle
of Brent crude currently changing hands
at 77.99 so Barrel that's up a little
over a third of one percent on the
session on the equity market stocks in
the Asia Pacific region had a largely
positive session overnight only Sydney
in Singapore they were the only
decliners in the region in Europe stocks
have also been trading largely to the
upside this morning as you can see all
of the main Continental European indices
in positive territory right now on a
huge day for company results talking
points include Deutsche Bank it shares
ahead by some two and three quarter
percent in Frankfurt on the back of
better than expected quarterly results
well here in London the ftse 100 is more
or less unchanged right now again there
are a huge number of results to digest
the leading Blue Chip Gainer just now is
Barclays that's on the back of its
results for your upbeat uh trading
statement I thought the shares up four
and a half percent there uni either
which I mentioned earlier in the program
that is also trading to the upside some
one and three quarter percent to the
good meanwhile the distributor RS group
is ahead by two and a half percent asked
news from an acquisition has been well
received to the downside the advertising
giant wpp is off two and three quarter
percent on its results while a number of
footsie heavyweights have gone
ex-dividend today in other words they've
adjusted lower to reflect the fact that
they're trading for the first time
without the rights to the latest payout
lots of them in the ftse today those
going X div today include relics legal
in general and uh right move you can see
on the screen there that's off a 31
fresn Neo is another one the silver mine
that's off one and three quarter percent
don't worry if you're a shareholder in
that it's just because it's gone
ex-dividend today outside the ftsee
Capricorn energy is off by nearly 10
percent that is after it posted a big
operating loss but Drax group the power
generator is topping the ftse 250
leaderboard for a second day running on
enthusiasm at its own share buyback
program that shares three quarters of
one percent higher just now on the FX
markets or the Euro has come close today
to its highest level against the US
dollar for a year Sterling unchanged
more or less against either the dollar
or the Euro well joining me this morning
is Danny sarin but he's a fun manager at
Pacific Asset Management Danny good to
see you this morning let's start with uh
AstraZeneca very very confident trading
update the share price hasn't really
moved yeah I think that reflects a bit
of a travel and arrive situation the
stock had been performing very well in
the run-up to these results a very
strong set of results somewhat
um massaged a little bit by some
one-time income phasing there but
overall a very impressive set of numbers
and we look forward now to a significant
pipeline news flow particularly around
its oncology drugs that are in
development and that should be coming
this quarter and later in the year
absolutely I mean it feels on on the
pipeline that the the good news just
keeps on coming from this company yeah
under Pascal stereo it's been a
tremendous turnaround and success story
it's not that long ago Astra was subject
to a takeover approach from Pfizer and
now astrazeneca's Market cap is higher
than pfizers so you know he's done a
tremendous job
bringing that company forward bringing
through new product Pipeline and that's
driving future success for the company
yeah now yesterday of course we heard
from GSK yastra's big rival and again a
company that a lot of investors had
fallen out of love with in recent years
but now rekindling their affections yeah
I think there's still a big
underappreciation of the change that has
been affected under Emma wilmsley their
CEO and the company absolutely
delivering on its numbers yesterday are
also very much committed to it's better
than five percent Top Line growth and
better than 10 earnings growth in the
coming years and I think there's a much
growing or better appreciation of what
they're doing with their pipeline they
just this morning got a positive
recommendation from the European
regulator for its RSV vaccine which is a
multi-billion dollar opportunity as well
as then other business development that
they've been very active on not least
more recently they made an acquisition
of a small U.S biotech company for a
couple of billion dollars now also today
we've heard from Unilever Alan joke
purpose bowing out a CEO well he's gone
off on a reason being good note hasn't
he yeah I mean again a Unilever and in
fact the broader Consumer Staples group
have been delivering as promised in
terms of being able to put through quite
significant chunky price increases
without too much impact on the volume
side of the equation and unilever's
results flattened a little bit today by
a pipeline stocking on deodorant sales
but overall a very good set of numbers
and again that they've been continuing
to push through price and the consumer
seems to be being able to absorb that
just right now all right Danny I'm
afraid we want to leave a push for time
today but hopefully see you again soon
thank you thank you
oh the UK's electric truck sector
suffered a blow recently when arrival
one of the leading startups in the
sector scrap plans for electric cars and
buses and announced it was cutting a
thousand jobs in an attempt to save
money that doesn't mean electrification
in the sector is flagging biffer the
waste management company has today
announced a contract with Silverstone
based Lunas to convert the first 10 of
its 2 900 strong Fleet of diesel lorries
to Electric who are joining me now to
talk about this is the chief operating
officer at biffer Maxine Mayhew Maxim
welcome to you how long does it take
roughly to convert a diesel truck to
Electric
well there's a huge amount of activities
you can probably imagine and the team
here at Lunas do a great job doing that
um it takes probably several weeks about
five weeks to actually make that
actually come alive and get an upcycled
truck so for having been diesel right
through to being a fully electric zero
emission truck
and how much will it cost you to convert
the entire fleet
well as you've already said our current
Fleet is around 2 900 Vehicles that's a
lot of vehicles what we're planning to
do here is obviously as Vehicles get to
the end of their useful life we will
work with Lunas to have those have
another lease of life so to be upcycled
and recycled into a fully electric truck
so it's going to take a long time but
the reality is that the cost
effectiveness of doing this both in
terms of emissions but also in terms of
day-to-day running absolutely makes it
worthwhile for us I presume that is far
more cost effective for you than buying
all new trucks
it's really great to kind of break that
cycle of always having to replace with
new when you get to the end of life of
something you know we work with our
customers to help them recycle reuse and
reduce their waste so it's only right
that we do that with what is core to our
business and that's our collection Fleet
I mean these are a big beasts I remember
with affection driving a bin Lorry
around a racetrack some 20 odd years ago
I mean the the batteries that are
required to power them are huge can you
do this without any loss of efficiency
or performance
well obviously for us making that
transition from our traditional diesel
fleet it's really important that what we
end up with is as reliable can do the
duty and and manage everything we need
to from Collections and this isn't just
about transforming a 26 ton vehicle this
is about all of the clever stuff at the
back end that allows the compacting and
the physical collection of recycling and
refuse materials so you know what I'm
really delighted about working with
Lunas is they've done a lot of trial and
testing to make sure that we absolutely
continue to get what we need in terms of
quality so that we can service our
customers as you'd expect us to so you
know you can see one of the trucks
behind me today they are indeed big
beasts I haven't had the chance to take
it around Silverstone maybe one day but
but actually you can see how much needs
to happen to make that be an electric
truck
and in terms of charging are you having
to install facilities at your Depots to
that end
well obviously to have an electric truck
work you need to be able to charge it
recharge it so yes we are continuing to
invest in our charging infrastructure
across some of our key Depots to make
sure that actually we can use these
vehicles where they make most sense are
most effective for us help us with our
root efficiency and kind of Drive the
best overall impact having electric
Fleet as part of our overall flame and
Before I Let You Go Maxine obviously
biffer was bought last year by energy
Capital Partners the private Equity Firm
has much changed within the business
apart from all these these wonderful
initiatives you're carrying out like
this one
well as you can see we're carrying on
with our business plan and our
trajectory as a business I'm it's great
that we continue to invest in Innovation
continue to innovate to make sure that
we move forward as a business so you
know ECP recognized the strength of the
industry the strength of our business
and and that's why you know they took us
private so you know things are changing
but they're things that are on our
business plan and our growth Journey as
a business generally
and crucially the trucks remain Scarlet
of course
absolutely we've got our biffer read
through and through so look forward to
seeing them on a Road near you excellent
well I look forward to seeing you again
Maxi good to see you this morning thank
you
now according to the office for National
statistics between September last year
and January this year one in six of the
workforce was still working solely from
home while more than one in four were
splitting their working time between the
home and the office but with a growing
number of employers wanting colleagues
back in the office full time for having
to think about the office environments
people want these days well it's
something on which the global design and
Architecture Firm Gensler has been
working and joining me now to talk about
this is the strategy director at Gensler
Jane clay you've done a lot of research
Jane on this what makes people want to
come into the office these days it's
really about community
and being back I think really people
want to get back to normal
the idea of coming back to the office is
really around people's strengths of
community and culture people want to
come back to get on with work is
effectively what it's about what are the
amenities that people want in the office
these days interesting question there
are a number of things that people are
asking for what they're really asking
for is choice and with that comes things
like surprisingly rest and nap spaces
has come out number one and by that we
don't mean people want a bed in the
office funnily enough what they actually
want is space to get away from Machinery
space to get away from phones supposed
to just be quiet and do something other
than work because that's about the work
style lifestyle blur that people expect
now from the workplace also things like
Library spaces they expect obviously a
cafeteria but they expect much more
choice in those amenities and that's
something that not only organizations
need to think about and designers need
to think about but it's also something
that developers and landlords need to
consider when they're looking at
developments particularly in the city of
London absolutely I mean is this largely
Millennials and gen Zed as or is it also
cynical genexes like me no actually
surprisingly it's everybody
the older Generations are less likely to
work from home and they have more
presence in the office and because
they've got used to working from home
they actually have got used to having
Choice as well so they too want choice
in how they spend their time in the
office
what about the employees themselves I
mean from what you're saying this is
this is going to involve a lot of
investment
not necessarily I think that it's about
transforming some spaces you already
have and using them more wisely for
instance a lot of organizations used to
spend a lot of money on large meeting
spaces what we are finding from some of
our other research is that large meeting
spaces just don't cut it people want
more intimate spaces so it's quite easy
to transform and transform something
large into something smaller also I
think it's about just designing for
flexibility from the get-go so that you
can easily change and adapt something so
the investment doesn't always have to be
high
what uh sense do you get that company
management are actually moving with
their workers on this are they being led
by the workforces that's also a good
question I think that if management
don't respond to what their workers want
then they will lose Talent eventually I
think there was a wonderful quote from
somebody at PWC who said the war for
talent is over the talent won which I
think you know whether One Believes
that's true or not it's also something
to watch out for because younger
Generations certainly have a sense of
you know a career isn't forever so
they're much more likely to say I have
better choice I have a better
environment I have a better lifestyle
work style balance somewhere else but I
think it behooves us as employers and
managers of people to look at what they
really need for their own health their
own mental well-being and actually
issues around neurodiversity actually
what people need to do their best work
and be their most productive selves we
need to look at that I find all this
absolutely fascinating the fact that you
talking about the need for quiet spaces
and things like this because when I
entered the workforce 30 odd years ago
it was all about open plan everyone was
going open plan offices were boundaries
were being knocked down it kind of feels
like the cycle has turned a little it
has and funnily enough I entered the
workforce at the same time as you so I
I've seen it all and obviously designing
these spaces we go through Cycles but I
think it was inevitable that it would
come back to the issue of choice
particularly you know during the
pandemic people have got used to choice
in how they worked at home you could be
at your kitchen table you could go and
work on your sofa fundamentally that's
all people are asking for from the
workplace essentially is that they want
to have choice in how they do their work
in an environment that enables them to
be their best and I think if we enable
them to do that that's going to give you
better bit of business performance
because you enable people to be more
productive in the way they want to be
productive so I think it's been an
inevitable change and the pandemic just
helped us nudge that along a bit faster
all right go over there Jane I'm afraid
good to see you this morning thank you
Now reminder to you to check out the
inking live podcast you can find that by
scanning the QR code on your screen now
it's available now wherever you get your
podcasts including the Sky News app
Apple and Google podcasts and Spotify
was still to come here on air King live
have rising cost pressures are leading
some Farmers to diversify in unusual
ways to go away
[Music]
can we have a closer for the medals and
then we can talk about them
so we start with the the main piece
that's a cross-section the Bounty we've
got malteser Twix let's do it slowly
maltesers Twix Bounty a bounty chocolate
Galaxy yeah galaxy uh a Milky Way Milky
Way of course and uh Snickers I think at
the end Snickers at the end and what
about on his lapels the the epaulettes
we have I kept making that mistake sorry
we got yeah bounties and galaxies and
milky ways and Twix and you can see in
the collar which was the trickiest bit a
whole line of Milky Ways and the ends of
the maltesers
which I've used up the the ends that we
cut to make the original maltesers yeah
the bits you cut off you put around the
collar at the top that's right and you
styled it on looking at hours and hours
of footage of him yeah that's right yeah
and and then from there made lots of
sketches and Tim Simpson the sculptor
created the head and Clay first so we
had to get that just right because
obviously everybody knows what Charles
looks like we didn't want to get that
wrong and then created a mold and I cast
it in chocolate and then reused
um yeah nearly 17 liters of of melted
celebrating chocolates
uh well hopefully we're gonna share it
with everybody and uh and you're going
to take it along the Route on the day or
who you're sharing it with we're not
quite sure yet but I think I think we've
got lots of people to show it to you
first yeah and is it solid
this is solid okay solid you're not
saying our King's an airhead are you
well there is a little bit of it brim to
breathe exactly amazing how much you
think it's worth no idea oh Priceless
yeah to me and I know it was an absolute
schlep but my goodness me absolutely
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
made local
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
thank you
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
welcome back now the pressures facing
the farming industry have been well
documented many farms are struggling to
trade profitably even before Putin's war
in Ukraine caused the price of energy
fertilizer and animal feedstocks to
Rocket as a result many farmers have
sought to diversify away from their core
activities but among them is Jason
Barber a fifth generation Dairy Farmer
in West Dorset and his friend and
neighbor Paul archert the pair hit on
the idea of distilling vodka from milk
and black cow is now being widely
distributed I'm very pleased to say Paul
and Jason join me now welcome to both um
Jason let me start with you first when
did you hit on the idea of distilling
vodka from milk
um well basically if you have milk cows
that drives you to drink
um and then you've got to get up in the
morning so um we wanted to make a vodka
which is nice clean and smooth and socks
which milk is a great uh product and
very under utilized
so um yeah we start to make it for milk
and it was it's very clean and very
smooth
I gather the the technique the processes
is many centuries old
Yeah well yeah that's correct
um nothing's new as we know and in
Mongolia Kyrgyzstan Kazakhstan nomadic
tribes have been making a treat on a
Friday night out of what's left over
from their milk because in in cold arid
climates you can't grow crops which have
enough sugar and they subsist on their
milk so this goes back five or six
thousand years
um Genghis Khan's hordes would um you
know would take this with them as they
went across Europe well I hope your
customers aren't uh carrying on like uh
Genghis Khan and his uh gang dead I mean
what was the thinking behind the the
black cow brand you I mean you had to
launch the brand and come up with this
what what did you get what went into
that
well we thought what's the simplest name
that that symbolize our brand and that
will work well internationally as well
because we've always got our eye on in
on other regions and I've noticed a
combination of colors and animals seems
to work quite well for a lot of other
brands and the cow is where our our
single Source product comes from it just
comes from cow's milk nothing else and
black is a is a sort of the luxury
limited color so there are lots of other
we've taken our cues from a lot of
people black editions of things and and
it's a great it's a great uh music track
by Steely Dan as well all right Jason
what about uh has this enhanced the
sustainability of your business
financially speaking
um it it helps it helps
um because I'm spending less time on the
farm and doing more things here so
um you know you can keep your labor
short down at the farm
um so yeah no it all helps definitely
you're also uh you've got you sell a lot
of cheese as well what's the proportion
of of turnover now accounted for by the
Volker brand
well we I it's about 90 vodka and about
10 uh cheese but the the great thing
about our product is that it's made up
from what's left over from cheese
production so it's not only the
smoothest smoking world it's also the
most sustainable because we've it is
made out of a very under-resourced
product which is whey which is left over
when you make cheese so it kind of yeah
and what would you have previously done
with all that way
well years ago we would have uh fed it
to the pigs the pigs you know there mark
would have gone on the grounds made the
grass grow uh the cows eat the grass and
you make your cheese to feed the way
back and that's that was the sort of
Dorset Somerset cycle
so we think we've got a better use for
it
Paul what about uh I mean it's a
fascinating concept and as you say one
that's centuries old but did you
encounter much skepticism in terms of
trying to bring it to Market
well we did we did in a way that's
really good because it's slightly
provocative you know we we'd say people
go I can't believe it's made out of milk
and then they'd try it and a lot of
people have got very in love with gin
over the last few years and people are
coming back to Vulcan they go you know
I'm not really a talking drinker but I
can drink this it's so smooth and this
is what we find time and time again when
they try our product so it's that
initial is this quite right and then
they try it and we're winning a lot of
hearts and minds and palettes with our
product because of it we've only got
about 20 seconds left are you mainly
distributed through the uh the off trade
right now
we are we're off trade and on trade
we're in most major supermarkets and
we've now signed a distribution deal
with most and cause who are the biggest
drinks distributors in the country so
this should really open us up to some
exciting commercial possibilities in the
next year yeah it's fascinating guys
we're out of time I'm afraid thanks very
much for joining us good to see you both
thank you so much
that's it from me I'm back tomorrow
morning at 10 o'clock hope very much to
see you then chain SEC is up next do
stay tuned for all the latest including
the RCN court case and the gambling
white paper cheerio